okay guys it's your boy psychobabble  we're gonna do an erequest let's say  here okay quest oh man  okay I guess again the new Guardian  connection okay carefully and at the  crossroads I guess that's right here ask  the agent called Hendrik hello sir  prowl wow that's a pad a little of thing  it's like a Dixie cup yes  you gotta go the back way for you  haven't finished my drink yet man I  should have rested up a little bit yeah  bet I got this hats actually wants an  axe nice one to get a ding  now you rest up real quick Jake you  still what happens I guess guys are  gonna show me where the padded but I'm  just gonna sleep on the floor right here  yeah safety you know you take one in a  room you know just like save a lot Oh